I didn't even really like business I
really really didn't that was boring to
me I'm but I had an idea and I had a
dream and I thought people need this
product you have to be driven you have
to be motivated you have to have passion
you have to be somebody who like I said
there are no no's if you want to start
your own business you really need to put
in the time of the dedication and that
means 24/7 if need be if you really have
a drive and you really put your heart
and soul into something you can really
make anything happen she's an American
inventor entrepreneur and TV personality
she's best known as a cast member on the
reality TV show shark tank
she has helped launched over 400
products and holds 120 foreign and US
patents she's Lord Grenier and here's my
take on her top ten rules for success
also guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people could be inspired by your sharing
and also when you write it down you're
much more likely to lock it into
yourself to enjoy
I just had an idea
I was always thinking of things I was
always creative and had no plan on which
to make products or be an inventor I
didn't even really like business and
really I really didn't that was boring
to me on but I had an idea and I had a
dream and I thought people need this
product and I got the bug and once you
get the bug and you realize you can do
it then you just keep doing more and
more and more because you want the
direction yeah it is and you don't
really want to stop it's like you
there's never really like and you think
there's an end goal but then you always
know there's something more to be done
or buyers of stores for me it was the
you know TV shopping world for me and
it's late and you can't clean okay yeah
I once you have a successful product and
and women for me that was the audience
at the time women loved it then you want
to keep pleasing you want to keep
creating things that make them happy
that make their lives better and you get
personal gratification but then you also
know that you're helping other people in
their lives so that for me was quite
infectious I just wanted to keep doing
and making more and it became easier and
easier because I knew what I was doing
I'm a woman in business over you and
it's great because they're different
personalities successful be yourself
take care of business
be yourself or yeah and out there but it
can be bumpy along the way any regrets
or mistakes that you feel you've kind of
hit through the years well you know I
share certain bumps that I've had in the
book I think that you know I don't like
to look back there are no mistakes
really everything is a learning lesson
and everything helps you to do better so
I talk about some of the mistakes that I
made and it just helps you to get
further along learn from those mistakes
and get smarter my entrepreneurial
spirit flourished when I started
thinking of ideas and then seeing the
mouth on the market but I hadn't done
that
someone else had they were very
successful so when I thought of my
earring organizer I thought this time
I'm going to do it and I did
I knew that women had no good way in
which to store their jewelry and it just
came to me like a thunderbolt and I went
home and I drew it and then I went to my
grandfather's wood shop and I made it
after I made my sample I did market
research to see if people would really
like it or buy it I started calling
every retailer in the country let it
ring a thousand times until they'd pick
up and I flew myself to 21 cities and 18
days and met with different buyers and
showed them my prototype that first
product was very successful
I made well over a million dollars on it
and I started thinking wow there's lots
of other things I could make and I
started making cosmetic organizers I
started doing kitchen gadgets my goal
was to improve people's lives with the
products that I created to date I've
created over 400 products and I've
generated a pavilion and sale to me an
entrepreneur is somebody who will do
whatever it takes right they're driven
they are a type personalities they it's
like they don't know the word no and
that's always been my mantra I know no
knows just how can I so when I see that
person I know that no matter what even
if they have to pivot you know which is
something that happens maybe this isn't
the best idea but something else is and
you're going to change it they're still
going to make it because they have what
it takes to be a successful entrepreneur
new business formations are way down way
down way down and venture capital is way
down well that means people are afraid
of something these are brand new
business startups a very important
economic measure way down well I think
you know to me I'm an entrepreneur and I
think that true entrepreneurs it doesn't
really matter what's going on in the
economy if they come up with a great
business idea great product they're risk
takers they're going to go for it it
doesn't matter if the taxes are up 5% it
doesn't matter what is going on with
that they are people that just are
pioneers they're going to forge ahead
and start that business no matter what
well I've launched in the last 16 years
400 new products and I have a hundred
and fifteen pens people going through
this now have a lot of options you have
a fundraising sites like Kickstarter you
have little online marketplaces like
Etsy do you recommend that people use
these to sort of test out their products
I think a lot of people don't trust
their gut enough I think a lot of people
want somebody to hold their hand through
the process and really that's not the
best way there's no special formula
that's right for every single person you
have to decide do you like Kickstarter
do you feel that's right for you or you
know people have other ways in which to
do things so I think it's know your
options let's all feel good when someone
brings you a new idea well I love it I
mean that's what drives me I love the
excitement of taking a product and
turning it into a huge success so you
know that's what Shark Tank is all about
and that's what my book is all about
it's exciting what are some of the key
traits to being a successful inventor
well I think definitely you have to be
driven you have to be motivated you have
to have passion you have to be somebody
who like I said there are no no's you
know if I have an obstacle I go over it
I go under it I go around it
you just don't quit I go through it I go
through it well I think that startup
should one be willing to do everything
that it takes to make their startup work
you know a lot of people say oh well you
know I just want to do it for a few
hours a day that's not going to happen
if you want to start your own business
you really need to put in the time of
the dedication and that means 24/7 if
need be make sure whatever your idea is
that people really want it and need it
and the way to learn that is to do some
market research don't just ask friends
and family get out there and ask a lot
of people in a variety of people if they
like your idea and if they would buy it
use it or pay for it and if so what
would they be willing to pay make sure
that you've done all of your research
and what it takes to get your product
idea out there so have a business plan
and find out all the steps required
first so that you're not missing
anything along the way and you don't
mess any
up make sure that you learn all the
people that you can market your product
to stores shopping channels whatever it
is make sure that you know them and that
you're aggressive and you're very
enthusiastic and passionate about your
product idea or business because your
enthusiasm becomes infectious if you
believe in yourself they will too if you
really have a drive and you really put
your heart and soul into something you
can really make anything happen I'm a
true believer in that so I think that we
hopefully we make people believe that
they can achieve the American Dream -
just watch study us and if you really
are passionate and driven you can get
there
my true feeling is this no matter who
you are no matter what age you are no
matter the time in your life if you have
a dream and you have the drive you can
make anything happen and if you are ever
feeling down or feeling like you can't
get over that hump or you just have a
bad day I play this song and you
remember this song okay here it goes
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because old world girl
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you having a profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from Laurie today that had the biggest
impact on you what was your favorite
clip and why and what are you going to
take from today's video and immediately
apply somehow to your life or to your
business leave it down the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to bleed OD thank you so
much a picked up a copy of my book dear
one word and posting that picture online
it really really really means a lot to
me and I hope you're enjoying the book
as well so thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon